good morning John I'm on a plane no I'm
on the ground no I'm I'm on a plane I'm
on the ground I'm on a plane I'm on the
ground I'm on a plane on the ground
[Music]
what am i doing am i doing I'm in an
airport what am i doing man I'm making a
video
something smells a lot like gerbils with
their gerbils on this plane I was just
watching the news up here um you can't
get away from the news when you're in an
airport that is one of the fundamental
laws of traveling
there's always news apparently it is
okay for quadriplegics to own guns my
favorite things about writing planes is
the view out the window it makes me kind
of nauseous but I really love look we
got it checked and check it out yeah
yeah that's that's a good day for
looking at landscape I mean duh just
because he can't use something doesn't
mean you can't own it I mean lots of
grandmas have internet connections they
can't use them what they have them I
think I figured out what the gerbil
smell was I think that the parents
behind me are using the the smell of
cedar to overwhelm the smell of baby
poop it's not working anymore
hello I'm back home I'm here to tell you
that Nathalie communitychannel told us
to tell you what your favorite toys from
your childhood was this is mine
there's Dexter's is still fair and I
slept with him every day from when I was
six till it was 15 someone's hitting a
few seats up for me who's reading a
story about Octomom and how she lost 145
pounds and I'm like yeah she lost 145
pounds when she gave birth to eight
children I hate people who are like
first class is such a crass an
inappropriate example of all the classes
classism in our world that's not first
class you're thinking of oh no this guy
gets to sit on a slightly bigger chair
than I do because he has more money
I think the crass and inappropriate
example of class you're looking for is
the fact that rich people get to fly
across the country all the time so they
can see their friends and families and
do all kinds of cool business while
people who don't have money don't have
that opportunity in their lives just
saying I have that opportunity I have an
interesting plane neighbor you know what
do you do sound engineer from Blues
Traveler so you travel around the Blues
Traveler that's or about my
was that like it's cool it's fun at
first and then slowly tapers and I
really want to go
yeah I mean I'm expecting that's me
about how my tour goes it's amazing how
I can hate something so amazing I sit
down in a chair in Missoula Montana and
then I stand up from that chair and I am
in Seattle like I've been going like 300
miles per hour to the sky I should be
like well that's not what I'm like
instead my reaction to flying 300 miles
through the air is a lot more like hmm
and now I'm going to show you some
random clips from my trip this is
Seattle downtown Seattle from the air
hello Seattle and the Mountaineer and
this is a wheel cart apparently I like
that and then this landing landing now
poof of smoke and everything pretty cool
this guy had a snake on his head I
wasn't very impressed by that and just
in case anybody has any troubled teens
San Francisco I will see you in two days
everyone else you have to wait your turn
I'm gonna put that graphic up one last
time even though I don't have any new
information for those poor people in
Seattle
[Music]
you